wir schalten nach Kiew zu unserem
Kollegen Robert Kempe Herr Kempe in
kerschon wir haben es gerade gesehen in
dem Bericht sind offenbar sieben
Menschen bei Angriffen der Russen
getötet worden schon zuvor ja hatten die
Behörden die Menschen aufgefordert die
Stadt zu verlassen wie reagieren die
Leute vor Ort machen sich jetzt viele
auf den Weg Weg dorthin dort weg
laut letzten Meldungen sollen sogar zehn
Menschen gestorben sein bei den letzten
Angriffen der russischen Artillerie und
über 50 heißt es verletzt was wir wissen
was wir hören aus der Sonne ist es dass
man damit begonnen hat dass man
Krankenhäuser evakuiert die Menschen die
Patienten die dort sind werden in andere
Städte gefahren zum Beispiel nach
mikularia oder nach Odessa was ungefähr
ja dreieinhalb bis vier Stunden von dort
entfernt liegt die Situation hat sich
dort in den letzten Tagen immer mehr
zugespitzt wir sind dort vor einer Woche
ungefähr gewesen mehrere Tage kurz nach
dem Herrn befreit wurde auch da haben
wir immer wieder Artillerie Beschuss
durch die russischen durch die russische
Armee vernommen das hat sich in den
letzten Tagen dort ähm ja verschlimmert
die Angriffe haben zugenommen auch
Wohngebiete werden dort weiter ins
Visier genommen von der russischen Armee
so dass man davon ausgehen muss dass man
auf das Angebot der ukrainischen
Regierung dort die Stadt zu verlassen
dass da mehrere Menschen darauf eingehen
aber man muss auch berücksichtigen dass
viele Menschen die dort sind gar nicht
wissen wo sie sonst hin sollen weil
nicht viele haben Verwandte woanders und
die Menschen kommen dort nicht an ihr
Geld gerade ran das heißt auch in andere
Städte zu fahren der Ukrainern sich dort
ein Leben aufzubauen ist für viele ganz
schwer möglich die Stadt war ja fast
neun Monate unter russischer Kontrolle
und nennt viele Menschen sind ja von
dort schon geflohen damals die die es
sich leisten konnten die die Optionen
hatten aber viele sind geblieben
darunter eben sozial Schwache und eben
auch die ältere Bevölkerung nun hat ja
Präsident selenski in seiner Ansprache
in der Nacht den Widerstandsgeist seines
Volkes gegen die Russen gerade zu
beschworen wie sieht es denn damit aus
wie ist der Wille ungebrochen den Russen
zu widerstehen
wir sind nach den massiven russischen
Luftangriffen auf die Infrastruktur vor
zwei Tagen hier in der Stadt immer
unterwegs gewesen um eben der Frage
nachzugehen wie geht auch die
kiefer-bevölkerung mit dieser
Problematik gerade um die Menschen mit
denen wir gesprochen haben die sind
weiterhin
vollkommen überzeugt dass man diesen
Angriffen weiter standhalten wird auch
wenn die Temperaturen langsam die
Minusgrade gehen und niemand weiß wie
der Winter wird in der Ukraine kann es
ja gut minus 20 Grad werden im Winter
teilweise ist man gewählt dem zu
widerstehen die Menschen mit dem wir
gesprochen haben die sagen wir haben
vorgesorgt wir haben Wasser uns besorgt
wir haben vorgekocht wir haben andere
Lebensmittel bereit dass wir wenn z.B
wieder zu einem Blackout kommen sollte
dass wir dem eben standhalten können
also der der Widerstandsgeist der Mensch
mit denen wir gesprochen haben ist
derzeit und wieder brauchen eine
ungebrochen aber natürlich ist es
schwierig eine Prognose zu wagen was
passiert wenn es wieder einen Angriff
geben könnte durch die russischen
Truppen und es widerstrom aus vergibt
und das Wetter nicht so mitspielt
nämlich und das weiter Minustemperaturen
gibt und der Winter wieder stärker wird
der Kämpfe sprechen wir über die
militärischen Erfolge der Ukraine
Militärexperten im Westen sagen es sei
nun wichtig für die Ukraine nicht Inhalt
zu halten sondern weiter vorzurücken was
ich ja vor allem auf die Region Carson
bezieht was hören sie denn rücken die
ukrainischen Truppen tatsächlich vor
was wir hier hören bezüglich Herr Sonnen
ist derzeit nicht viel von Seiten der
das ukrainischen Generalstab zum
Beispiel oder der ukrainischen Regierung
es ist ja so dass die Stadt direkt am
Fluss Nepal liegt und die Brücke in Herr
Sonne die über den knappe früher führt
der zerstört wurde beim Rückzug der
russischen Truppen das heißt es ist
natürlich schwierig für die ukrainische
Armee den Fluss derzeit zu überqueren
auch weil es immer wieder heißt dass die
russische Armee dort ihre
Verteidigungslinien stärker gefestigt
hat das darauf schließen lässt eben
warum die Stadt Herr Sonne in letzter
Zeit immer massiver von russischer
Artillerie ins Visier genommen wird was
wir aber auch immer wieder hören ist
dass es Weizen ist nicht 60 km teilweise
70 km hinein in Russisch kontrolliertes
Gebiet was schon an auch an die
krim-grenzt das ist dort immer wieder
Explosionen geben soll und das lässt
darauf schließen dass natürlich die
ukrainische Armee mit diesen mehrfach
Raketenwerfer die sie haben also diese
Heimat
Systeme die sie von den US-Amerikanern
bekommen haben dass man die eben auch
näher an den Fluss nepre geführt hat und
dort eben russische Stellungen ins
visieren nimmt
woanders sieht das aus oder prekäre
sieht das aus in der Ostukraine derzeit
dort versucht man natürlich auch Gebiete
wieder zurück zu gewinnen aber gerade in
der Gegend rund um bachmut rund um Don
jetzt ist es wohl so dass die russischen
Truppen dort leicht in die Offensive
kommen aber das Wetter ist natürlich
auch problematisch in diesen Regionen
also muss man schauen ob überhaupt
offensiven von beiden Seiten so
überhaupt noch durchführbar sind denn
auch in der Ostukraine hat der Winter
eingesetzt auch dort liegt Schnee auch
dort wird es problematischer
militärische Operation durchzuführen und
es gibt auch die Meldung dass ich eben
in Teilen gerade in der Ostukraine es
schon wieder er auf einen positionskrieg
zurückführen lässt dass massiv wieder
nur mit Artillerie geschossen wird so
wird schon vor einigen Monaten hatten
Robert Kämpfe war das aus Geschäft zur
militärischen Situation in der Ukraine
danke für Ihre Zeit und danke auch an
ihr Team